es sind selbst gemalte bilder die ihm
helfen seine gedanken zu verarbeiten der
26-jährige linus neumeier leidet
jahrelang unter einer starken psychose
ausgelöst durch regelmäßigen
cannabiskonsum
meistens mal ich ja immer kopfloser aber
ich glaube bei dem bett habe ich mir
gedacht
weil es nicht man in dem moment wenn man
eine panikattacke hat dann gibt mir ein
stück weit die kontrolle habt gefühl
zumindest und das soll das völlig
darstellen mit den einzelnen feldern die
man selber nicht in der antrag sozusagen
seinen ersten joint raucht er mit 18
jahren gemeinsam mit einem
schulkameraden
in der zeit nach der schule wird das
kiffen dann zur gewohnheit ihr gift
teilweise sogar mehrmals täglich die
größte motivation dahinter war
eigentlich
wenn ich ehrlich bin halt die
gruppendynamik also
es war bei weitem nicht so dass ich
jedes mal nach dem trip gesagt habe borg
cool das hat mir jetzt richtig gut
gefallen ich will das jetzt wieder haben
sondern es war halt mehr teilweise sind
erleichterung das ist jetzt vorbei ist
sozusagen ja und dann gab es wieder tage
an den cool daten hat spaß gemacht
rund 40 prozent der jungen erwachsenen
hat laut einer studie der bundeszentrale
für gesundheitliche aufklärung schon mal
gekifft cannabis zählt als die meist
konsumierte droge weltweit professor dr
maximilian gar warnt jedoch je jünger
der konsument desto höher ist das risiko
für folgeschäden und man konnte
feststellen dass bei personen die in
frühen lebensjahren also mit 13 14 15
beginnen viel zu konsumieren regelmäßig
konsumieren dass es dort zu chronischen
anhaltenden veränderungen kommt auch zu
veränderungen im gehirn und das sind
veränderungen die vor allem die vorderen
also die frontalen hirnbereiche
betreffen die einem allgemeinen mit
aufgaben wie problem lösen priorisieren
impulskontrolle emotionsregulation in
verbindung stehe man konnte hier bei den
früh
beginnen den chronischen konsumenten
eine volumen minderung im vergleich zu
den nicht konsumenten feststellen bevor
er mit dem kiffen begonnen hat hatte
linus neumann ja noch nie psychische
probleme nach mehreren monaten des
konsums erlebte er seine erste
panikattacke schwitzen
herzrasen
schlecht ist mir schwindelig
einfach die tatsache dass ich im kopf
alle gedanken
kreiseln also man kann keinen gedanken
mehr fassen kann
also
nicht der volle film heißt machen
einfach nur angst total doof zu
beschreiben aber man hat eigentlich das
gefühl man können sterben jede minute
oder das herz hört auf zu schlagen oder
ich höre auf einmal auf zu atmen weil
egal welcher versuche man startet das in
griff zu bekommen das haut nicht hin
aktuell wird zur genetischen ursachen
geforscht die das risiko für
folgeerkrankungen erhöhen aber auch die
zusammensetzung der droge hat einen
einfluss
man hat in den letzten jahren versucht
cannabis sativa pflanzen zu züchten in
den hohen thc-gehalt haben einfach weil
dann die psychotropen die psychische
effekte stärker sind und da spielt also
eine große rolle wir haben eine
untersuchung gemacht wir haben einfach
die stationären fälle in den jahren 2000
bis 2008 zehn untersucht und wir haben
also in diesem zeitraum in deutliche
zunahme der anzahl der fälle die wegen
einer psychischen störung aufgrund von
cannabis gebrauch in deutschen
krankenhäusern stationär behandelt
worden sind beobachtet insgesamt fast
fünf mal so viele dazukommen ambulante
patienten die linus neumeier seine
panikattacken häufen sich und er zieht
sich immer mehr zurück ein psychiater
diagnostiziert eine cannabis induzierte
psychose und verschreibt ein angst
lösendes antidepressivum in der
psychotherapie lernt der damalige
abiturient mit den plötzlichen attacken
umzugehen im prinzip
was ich selber gemerkt habe dass es wenn
man das zulässt dann wird es weniger so
irgendwie merkt man kriegt jetzt panik
oder angst dann muss dann habe ich mir
gedacht ja auch egal denn dann falle ich
halt in rom macht oder dann sterbe ich
halt keine ahnung und dann durch den
gedanken dass zu lassen so dass sich dem
öffnens ist es dann besser geworden mit
ärztlicher unterstützung entscheidet
sich linus neumayer trotz regelmäßiger
panikattacken für ein studium
es war halt nicht einfach gab auch tagen
vorlesen da muss ich dann nach fünf
minuten in der ersten vorlesung
rausgehen und
weiß nicht ausgehalten haben oder nicht
geschafft habe es im griff zu bekommen
aber dadurch habe ich halt auch eine
struktur in meinen alltag bekommen
und eine regelmäßigkeit
entgegen vieler gerüchte kann cannabis
abhängig machen was die prognose negativ
beeinflusst den wenigsten patienten
gelingt es wenn sie eine wirkliche
abhängigkeit haben bei dem ersten
versuch abstinent zu sein dann auch
wirklich abstinent zu bleiben also die
rückfallquote ist ja sehr hoch wenn der
patient weiter konsumiert und es ist in
der regel so dass der verlauf nicht so
gut ist wenn er aufhört ist er besser
aber es kann auch sein dass einige sowie
trotz des dessen weiter bestehen -
neumeier hat es geschafft und ist nach
sechs jahren psychotherapie symptomfrei
sein medikament möchte ebenfalls
schrittweise absetzen mit dem studium
ist er fertig mittlerweile arbeitet er
als bauleiter für ihn steht fest kiffen
wird er nie wieder
[Musik]